وائل هذه الصور اذا نشاهدها مره اخرى
لرشقات جديده من الصواريخ
هذا صحيح عثمان هي رشقتين متتاليتين من
زاويتين مختلفتين هذه المره في ولكن كلا
الزاويتين تقعان في المناطق الشماليه من
قطاع غزه وواضح بان الرشقتين
لصواريخ متوسطه او بعيده المدى على على
الاقل كما شاهدنا من طريقه اندفاع
الصواريخ
والملاحظ ايضا واللافت بان القبه الحديديه
لم تطلق كثير من القذائف الصاروخيه في
محاوله الاعتراض هاتين الرشقتين يعني على
سبيل المثال في الرشقه الاولى شاهدنا
اطلاق صاروخ واحد او صاروخين من القبه
الحديديه
لاعتراض رشقه تتكون من خمسه الى سته
صواريخ على سبيل المثال في الرشقه الثانيه
كانت ايضا القبه الحديديه اطلقت صاروخ
واحد
فقط في محاوله لاعتراض الرشقه الصاروخيه
التي تتكون من عدد كبير من الصواريخ الان
القبه الحديديه
اطلقت عددا من الصواريخ الغريب انه لم
يطلق صواريخ من قطاع غزه او على الاقل لم
نشاهد اطلاق الصواريخ بعد لحظات يعني نحو
عشر الى خمسه عشر ثانيه من اطلاق الرشقه
الصاروخيه ووصولها ربما الى اهدافها اطلقت
القبه الحديديه هذه القذائف الصاروخيه
وانفجرت في سماء تخوم محافظه الشمال في
قطاع غزه وهذا ربما جراء خلل ما اصاب
القبه الحديديه ولذلك لم تطلق القبه
الحديديه لم تطلق هذه الصواريخ ساعه اطلاق
الرشقات الصاروخيه من قطاع غزه ربما
يعني زياده عدد ووتيره هذه الرشقات ربما
اصاب هذه القبه الحديديه بخلل ما ربما
استنزف مخزونها من الصواريخ ربما التكتيك
المتبع باطلاق الرشقات الرشقه الواحده
باتجاهات متعدده فما بالك عندما يكون
الامر يتعلق بعده رشقات تنطلق بشكل متزامن
من مناطق مختلفه وبزوايا مختلفه وصواريخ
بمدايات مختلفه ايضا عثمان بالتاكيد هذا
التكتيك واضح في هذه الموجه من التصعيد
لجات اليه المقاومه الفلسطينيه منذ بدايه
اطلاقها الرشقات الصاروخيه